we're going to turn overseas now to the
war in ukraine where the mayor of the
besieged city of mariupol reportedly
says russian troops are interfering with
new efforts to evacuate civilians there
russia has nearly destroyed the
strategic seaport where hundreds of
civilians have taken shelter in a steel
factory about a hundred people left that
plant over the weekend but 200 more
remain one american official says russia
is making plans to swallow up that part
of eastern ukraine
here's chris livesay now with more on
the desperation in mariupol
people flee
but the shelling remains
and after six weeks of war tatiana no
longer flinches
she's watched as some 300 000 people
either escaped or died
you wake up and cry then you cry in the
evening says tatiana i have nowhere else
to go
this part of mariupol is now russian
occupied territory and the living have
become the undertakers
they pay rubles to sort through the
rubble and take out the corpses says
christina
95 year old jeff rocinia leaves her home
for what she fears could be the last
time
i want this putin to be battered she
sobs so he feels what we're going
through in a levee hospital this newly
married couple is battered but not
beaten after a mine tore off her legs
they're enjoying their first dance
out gunned and outsized ukraine has
compensated with heart
and creativity unafraid to blow up its
own bridges roads anything to slow down
the russians just outside keeve that
meant breaching this dam at great
civilian costs to the nearby town of
dimidiev
you can just see how the flood is
destroyed this part of the village
destroyed homes
possessions but they were happy to do it
because if they didn't the russians were
going to do it for them and effectively
saved their town in the process vladimir
a local villager roses through the
aftermath so the russian soldiers were
here
and russian shells maria warns us in her
vegetable garden invisible beneath us in
the murky water the same shelling rocked
her neighbor valentina's house and her
family of six hid inside the basement
while it slowly filled with water
we had to climb out she says but at the
same time the russians had to retreat
this water saved us
ukraine's ingenuity on the battlefield
is paying off the pentagon says russia's
invasion has shown quote minimal
progress at best suffering from poor
command and control and low morale
eureka
chris lives safe force in ukraine thank
you